my biggest recommendation for anyone  trying to move into a set of better  habits is start small don't boil the  ocean uh take a take any positive  progress you know day to day as a win  make your standard you make it a window  but have the bottom of that standard  where you can say did I pass yes low  have perfect as a ideal but accepted  like a day as a win if you if you get  some movement in and you and you eat  pretty decently and you get a little bit  of you know basic focus on sleep done so  that you're you're not just a train  wreck every day even when you don't make  that minimum standard you give yourself  a little Grace and get right back on the  horse because the problem is people are  like oh this is how I'm going to live my  life I'm going to change all these  habits and then they miss a day and then  they miss two days and then they're like  well I'll I'll start again next year